okay for those of you didn't wondered
what the test was about one anyway there
was a missing root in there once I
noticed it but I didn't want to spend
two yes okay so I want to do mainly two
things further I want to finally get
around to talking a little bit of
talking explicitly about the rate at
which these things which in reproductive
isolation arises in in specifically in
the best data system which is awful
assistan and then I want to turn my
attention to some ideas and observations
about about how to go forward with
studying these kind of things okay so
this is just a formalized how we how one
measures these kind of post mating
isolation you make reciprocal crosses of
the two taxa usually you would use maybe
the multiple accessions or multiple
individuals and you both replicate this
experiment a number of times and then
but they use a relatively qualitative
examination of the data they've just
looked to see whether there any males
survive and if the male survive are they
fertile or sterile and similarly the
females from this cross and that so
they're they're basically are for
individuals and there are two data
points sequential data points on each
individual is it alive and if its allies
is it fertile and then they have a
measure of this sort of index of post
post mating and oppose me the lady
isolation American index that's what
they call anyway so this is just to
capture the sort of amount of gene flow
in a very to the qualitative way a
quantitative quantitative way I guess is
what they say and this is what's used on
an extensive amount of data and
drosophila and other systems and so
that's this is the this index right here
and so over here at one
mean that either the individuals are all
all the individuals are dead or sterile
and of course over here is there no
effect but since there's they all have
some some isolation here so this is just
separating out sterility and those that
are sterile from those that are in
viable and both in viability and
sterility seem to accumulate with
genetic distance pretty much the same
rate and this represents quite a bit of
I think order of hundreds of pairs of
taxa now the question comes what about
pre mating isolation that these pre-made
eNOS is tortured by lots of behavioral
issues in with animals and so usually
it's not anything that we're terribly
proud of but it has to be fairly simple
and the assay that's used most widely in
this in the drosophila system is
basically just to put individuals in a
vial and let them compete and so then
you're scoring the ratio of matings
between the same species and matings
between between species and obviously if
there's complete pre mating isolation
that won't be any hetero specific
matings and again that's done with the
reciprocal crosses and you can see here
this is this very striking result is
that in in drosophila while the pre
mating isolation accumulates more or
less the same rate as a post mating
isolation with genetic distance the
sympatric species in other words species
that happen to occur together show a
very different pattern which you can
either be very impressed by and it's
certainly a fact worth remembering but
it in some sense it at least in a crude
way it might have to be this way that if
two species are some Patrick and they
don't show a lot of pre-made in
isolation then they will be in the
middle of a hybrid zone in any case the
pre made in isolation arises very
rapidly in
sympatric so that's the very sort of
fundamental result and in flies and
other organisms strive to get the sort
of clarity about this kind of issue
usually they don't have both kinds of
data in their book Conan or make this
this assertion here that this is a sort
of effectively reproductively completely
isolated when when the pre mating in the
post made in isolation the cumulative
isolation is at least ninety percent
then that they would think that's good
would be a good reproductively isolated
species and I and reading this last
night and thinking about what what
what's coming I realized that while this
might be quite good from the standpoint
of the evolution of sibling species in
terms of the overall direction of the
tax in other words when a species pair
reaches this kind of isolation for
whatever reasons obviously a lot of
deleterious effects on on there on the
fitness of the individuals there
probably are going to continue to
diverge in remain separate taxa but I
also realized that that means that
there's ten percent even in there good
species there's excuse me there's a ten
percent rate at which genes could be
crossing introgression between species
and I want to get back to that in a
little while so anyway this good leads
to a sort of estimate of about a million
years for the species as we talked about
before and now I want to turn our
attention to this issue here is what are
the what's what can we learn about the
actual process biological process that
underlies this isolation in in in
particular for post mating isolated
post-meeting postzygotic isolation how
which is as you'll see in a minute I'm
much easier to attack than pre mating
how rapidly does it evolve what can we
say about how it evolves
and are there can we recognize certain
components or pathways of biology that
are contributing to post mating
isolation in some excess or in some
unique way now one of the most
fundamental ideas in in this whole
business is the tip shamsky Muller oh
sorry danske Miller incompatibility so
if you have if you have a species that
has a a and b b and they make a hybrid a
be excuse me what am I say a 1 1 and
then the other species is a1 b1 one else
are a 2 this assumes that they're fixed
for alternative types then obviously the
heterozygote is is an a1 a2 heterozygote
and beach 1 B 2 and the thesis of job
Jansky Muller hypothesis about hybrid in
viability is that there's epistasis
between these genes either in this
heterozygote state or of course you will
see in a minute a more interesting case
would be when you have a homozygote for
a1 a1 in a background that is B 2 B 2 so
that you have homozygotes in general you
know genetic effects are stronger in the
homozygous setting so this is this is
the kind of setting that we're going to
be looking at next to try to ascertain
that but it's this epistasis but our
incompatibility between genotypes
derived from the two different answers
two different species that is the basis
of it this is a paper that addresses one
interesting question which I haven't
brought up one fact about post mating
isolation and in many organisms and this
was done in a very simple way
they had a pair of species that they
could hybridize and do crosses fairly
easily between but there were a lot of
sterols especially in this male sterols
and so they wanted to try to see if they
could map throughout the whole genome
and find as many of these as they could
in a fairly straightforward experiment
so what they did is they took a
transposon they put they they put a both
species had a background in which they
had flies happen to have white eyes and
then he had a transpose on that had red
eyes made it and they jammed they jumped
the transposon around the genome now
they weren't using they weren't going to
use the transposon to make mutants or
anything they just want to use it as a
marker because it will produce a
dominant marker as you'll see that they
can then select an integration
experiment so what you have here is a
typical examples right here is here's a
fly that now has the transposon
homozygous on one species background
over here we're going to back cross it
this is marciana and we're going to back
cross that too simulans and pick up a
heterozygote and then selecting on the
red eye color each generation you can
cross those females back to simulants
and eventually you can get a fly that is
very completely a simulant genome except
for this one small segment that's marked
with the red eyes and then by making
appropriate crosses you can make a
homozygote for that segmental
introgression and so basically they made
a lot of introgression zuv pieces of the
marciano genome into the into the
simulants genome and this is a map
showing you the many that they they
mapped in the genome after they mapped
them in they genotype them to see how
big the segments were and as you can see
here from the data they had a large
number of lines there were 145 lines
that they tested for both male and
female and male and female and in 76 of
those were male infertile while none
exhibited female fertility so that this
is an example of Hall danes rule
halt dein noticed long ago including the
donkey I mean the mule that the hetero
comedic sex is more often is more often
sterile in hybrids so in drosophila the
males are the header comedic sex like
humans they have a wide annex and so
it's it's typical and organisms that
have have ZW system it's a tense it most
of those are some of those that's can be
demonstrated that they also show all
Danes rule going the other way anyway so
that's one important thing and then the
the the other thing that they were able
to estimate is that they they got 15
such genes in that these species these
are very very very closely related
species and they already had 15 male
sterility fixations in the genome and
now chasing down these these particular
ones is still ongoing there's been some
success but in that case it's not so
clear but here's an independent study of
one such sterility gene in that same
species pair and this gene was mapped in
by very arduous genetic mapping it
caused recessive male sterility in the
hybrid and it turned out after a lot of
mapping that it was a it was a gene
duplication that occurred in the
ancestor of all these species not just
the simulans of Marciano one that they
were studying but the duplication
occurred long ago and and here it was a
duplication of a highly conserved gene
which has only ten substitutions on the
lineage going down to Mouse and in C
elegans two from the time of the
duplication in the functional Jane this
hunk genes excuse me involved in muscle
coordination in least in C elegans but
the gene was duplicated and the
duplicated gene as you can
see here evolve very rapidly expressed
in male gonads and in is a basically
shows one of the several of the most
important properties in the excess of
amino acid substitutions over silent
substitutions indicating strong
selection on the me know and the amino
acid sequence and an overall very high
rate of substitution divergence away
from the ancestral thing genotype so
presumably it's it's evolving some new
function yeah very rapidly so that's I
think the most important thing to take
away from this and would be a couple
more examples is it they are these these
genes that people have identified our
evolving seem to be involving quite
rapidly one way you could face that is
say well it almost has to be if you're
looking for the first gene that causes
male sterility it's going to be the one
that's evolving the most rapidly so it's
it's not a strong conclusion in terms of
other than that well it's a strong
conclusion that they're evolving rapidly
whether it's has to be that way how
strongly it is and how much bias
ascertain mattt there is it's a
difficult to judge huh by what oh
because all of the sterility that was
discovered by those introgression was in
males there were no female sterols right
let's do of something so something is
homozygous or something is that's on the
Y chromosome are these jeans all the way
no the none of them are on the y no no
but it's not it's it's a there is a
theory that attempts to explain it and
that has to do with with both the
dominance since it's hemizygous males
only have one chromosome and it also has
to do with the fact that in many
organisms the x chromosome seems to be
evolving more rapidly and so it could
it's a confounding of those two things
okay but in any case the males the
header comedic sex is more often
effective in the hybrid and then and
that's a true that's attributed both to
the more rapid evolution of the X and
also the Hemi zygosity of that it's
actually even if the thing that you need
to dress is not only X all the way it's
just select the most in fact if we go
back you'll see i'm pretty sure that
most of that is can I tell I can't read
it very well but it's certainly mostly
awesome if not all lot of song yeah but
the for example you can imagine that
that I mean there's two two explanations
one would be that the the genetic
interactions are inherently more
sensitive in males and that could be
attributable to the Hemis agassa T of
males the fact that they only have one X
but it could also just be true that the
X is evolving more rapidly and the males
are him in the evolving male sterility
more rapidly because of selection
generations I think it would be a
million years or simply half a million
years 2.3 oh he knows the 2.32 up and
back or just know it just this episode
of 4 million years of evolution between
a hey they didn't understand why do why
their genes that cause sterility
something to do with this what she wrote
on the whiteboard here yeah it's we the
model for what's going on here is that
one species if you make a particular
region and from derived from one species
homozygous in the background of the
other species then these genes will
interact badly do with one another and
lead to male sterility interaction yes
like the model is say that the ancestor
of both these species was like a 1a 1b
2b to know the ancestors a1 a1 b1 b1 so
one being the species oh okay okay yeah
this one is a 28 be to homothetic oh ok
sometimes sometimes the DM is right you
say that one gets 11 species 1 leitch
gets one mutation the other lage gets
the other doesn't really matter yeah
anyway okay yeah so and then so what you
have yours is you can think of be for
the background in this case because most
of the genome is derived from one genome
so many genes are be to derive from this
individual and we've integrate some
small part of the genome from a in there
made it homozygous okay well this pardon
me one doesn't like a one something
about a one is unhappy and be within the
b2 background that's a basic observation
so in genetic terms that would be
epistasis of interaction between genes
at different low side that's called
epistasis and and one of the one of the
things that this experiment doesn't
address that's important but it may be
is is the weather the interactions are
sort of pairwise or whether they
compound in other words there are 15 of
these things is that reflecting some
compounding interaction or not and it's
hard to judge in this case but that's an
open question sort of how to think about
the interaction should just be pairwise
between genes or or systematic the fact
that they're not all in at least so far
we haven't seen them all in one pathway
suggests that they might not be
compounding too quickly just because of
different pathways but it's not directly
demonstrate
okay so faster more amino acid
substitution indicating stronger
selection male our holidays rule applies
these now there's a one of the most the
longest studied hybrid in viability is
the is the cross between melanogaster
and simulans that species is that
crosses produces no fertile offspring
normally and for the last 80 or 90 years
that was a case but about 20 years ago
ashburner and Hunter found a strain that
actually allowed a hybrid male rescue
and that wasn't turned out to be a
variant or a mutant and it's been
studied and then later on in simulans
there was a lethal hybrid rescue which
rescued the lethality of another one of
the genotypes in the cross and so there
are two mutations or variants that have
been found in this this much more
ancient hybrid divergence but
nevertheless they are they rescue so
these are genes that so some change
occurs in them and now the hybrid
survive so they must be involved another
interesting set of genes but this is
it's is founding member in this story is
no 96 I'll get to it in a minute maybe
just brush over but anyway it's a nether
has many properties that are similar so
I'm going backwards so this is the third
one that I want to talk about these this
is a more recent one in and it has a
certain another all of these excuse me
these these genes how well as you'll see
we're all are more rapidly evolving and
this is the one of the more recent ones
this is in different species in pseudo
obscura and this gene seems to be
involved in genomic conflict it it
disturbs and not only causes sterility
but it also disturbs the transmission
ratio of the chrome
so it's involved in chromosome
transmission too and many people suspect
that genomic conflict just because
genomic conflict is so strong and can
lead to very rapid evolution and a few
systems where it's been been able to
study it that it could underlie a great
deal of the observed evolution of
sterility a hybrid sterility
alright guys yeah good thank you going
backwards genomic conflict is is is a
rubric for basically competition or
inner strong interactions selective
interactions between elements of the
genome directly rather than acting
through the phenotype of the individual
so in this case there's a piece that
there's a variant in the chromosome that
affects the transmission of the
chromosome it doesn't change the fly
it's you know its physiology or anything
else it affects the chromosomes own
transmission
there we go and I know it looks like I
got a few blank slides in here okay so
so let me just mention a few things that
you may have that are going to the so
transpose ax bilel iment can obviously
create genomic conflict in the sense
that they are very selfish self
replicating components of the genome and
they compete with the host genome for
resources and can they cause mutations
when they transpose and replicate and
and then there are mitotic drive
elements for example in the one of the
classic ones is that in corn in maize
populations natural populations or in
agricultural ones for that matter there
are elements on the chromosome that bias
Lee transmitted themselves during
meiosis so when the corn kernel is being
formed and meiosis occurs that the
individuals a heterozygote for one of
these they're called knobs because you
can see them in the microscope the knob
is transmitted more often than the non
knob so it's it's not affecting the way
the corn plant grows it's affecting its
own transmission conflicting with it
with the alternative allele which is
losing out in a very severe battle okay
so this is just that a little bit about
the that what's the proposed pathway for
this it looks like that lhr the male
hybrid rescuin and the lethal hybrid
rescue interact together in the pathway
this one is rescuing this is a milano
gasser mutant nas's simulans as i said
and they they there they seem to
interact the ridge them this is a
heterochromatin protein that binds to
the centromeric region are near the
centromere of malonic ester and this
second gene here is a has a very
characteristic pattern here you can see
of these every every whatever it is 489
basis there's a either leucine usually a
leucine or leucine like amino acid and
in this
species there's a insertion in that that
breaks that up and this is actually a
protein-protein interaction face which
the authors would like us to believe is
interacting with it with the image with
the hmr to produce the actual the chance
key molar incompatibility and they they
have genetic data to support that
interpretation another approach in by
the way I'm I'm slogging through a
little bit of genetics here because I
want to sort of motivate them the next
part so another approach with davin
press graves and a Leonora pursued and
Davin pursued much more strenuously is
to take drosophila has stocks which have
different little pieces of the genome
all deleted out individually one stock
after another and they took that stock
those stocks 180 or more of them and
they cross them and made him put them
into the hybrid and asked if the hybrid
if it if it caused a hybrid lethality in
in in the cross and they were looking
for genes that when they were made
haploinsufficiency they became lethal in
hybrid and they found a large number of
them are trove of them and the best one
was this note 96 the reason it was good
is that molecular and cellular biologist
had already worked very hard on this
gene it's very important in nuclear
transport and moving RNAs and other
particles and things in and out of the
nucleus and when when they looked at the
at the gene carefully they see that on
the simulants side where it looks like
the incompatibilities might be arising
on the lineage going down to simulans
and marshawn that sibling species
there's a large number of amino acid
substitutions and a couple and a
deletion of two base pairs are two
deletion I don't know Delta to what it
means a better back away anyway and only
eight synonymous substitutions whereas
typically there it there's an excess of
synonymous substitutions throughout the
rest of the
of the distribution of taxes so this is
a large excess of amino acid
substitutions on one lineage and an
acceleration of substitution on that
lineage so that well it's not really an
acceleration compared over there looks
like there's quite a bit of substitution
doing down there too anyway so this is
sort of pretty good evidence for again
rapid evolution in this gene now there
are a couple other genes that I I won't
mention but really we're up to about six
or seven and drosophila that are
well-studied well enough studied and the
general picture is that they the genes
that have evolved to give rise to
sterility and usually the genes
intervene studies or sterility or
lethality but are a couple at our
lethality they seem to be of course
favor in males and they are evolving at
a rapid rate and still too early to
really tell about the pathway they don't
have that much commonality in the
pathway or in the biology of the
function so it could very well be that
many pathways can be involved which is
the null hypothesis but the the the
point a time as i said i'm going to make
this this is an enormous amount of work
by large by many very bright
hard-working people and they made some
progress but if if the number of these
things is is high and the besides the
rapid rate the story about the biology
is not emerging terribly quickly it
seems to me that we need to really have
an have a better approach and i think
people have already started in although
they haven't I don't not sure it's been
thought out very well and for plants
there's there are a lot of interesting
situations where that can be studied in
plants and again they're not they're
usually for any one plant species
there's not the kind of resources that
it would take to really tear apart one
of these low sigh very deeply so we need
a little bit better approach to get at
it and I think really the way to go is
is to try to look at the whole genome in
sort of sequencing context and try to
see if we can find a way to identify
those genes that are contributing to
hybrids sterility hybrid and viability
and speciation say but I think once you
start to think about that then then at
least I immediately realize well we're
not this extends beyond the study of
hybrids are in speciation to really
anytime that populations become
separated and then come back together or
any kind of sort of merging of diverged
populations where their genes are
starting to be mixed from previously
separated and diverged populations and
so we all know about these kind of
classic models of migration and many of
the models can be a setup to have
periods of isolation and so forth so
that we can model and predict or at
least have a road forward for an
analysis of the whole genome to identify
those regions which show patterns of
either introgression or patterns of
differential migration between different
populations that can be hallmarks of
genes that are either favorably or
unfavorably selected as that as think as
time goes on so and to my mind is sort
of the simplest thing is we have these
sort of models of migration between two
populations or an ancestral population
separated and then some migration and
one of the things that I wanted to point
out here is that that in the previously
the amount of isolation that leads to a
good species still allows for a lot of
of gene flow and if you're looking at
the whole genome and ten percent of the
genome every generation could be
crossing or even one percent that would
still leave a lot of information about
that process in the genomes in the
population genomic analysis and in
particular as species become completely
diverged and completely isolated it
doesn't happen overnight it
is off and one can imagine that is that
there's still very rare opportunities
for gene flow between species that are
because if there are millions of hybrids
being produced or thousands it only
takes one to successfully reproduce at a
gene can transgressor int regress into
the other two species so I think this
whole issue of sort of being cognizant
of the differential migration is a in
migration models of multiple populations
is a as a very interesting area which is
a a lot of people are getting geared up
experimentally but I don't think the the
we don't have the sort of analytic and
stick to statistical tools to really
mine it for each of the kind of
biological questions that people might
want to ask and more specifically we
have models of the distribution of genes
that are selected in the hybrid zone
after secondary contact but we really
don't have a sort of full genomic
representation of how to analyze and
distinguish those genes that are very
strongly selected from those that are
very weakly selected for example one of
the most classic hybrid zone hybrid inva
and sterility cases are instances that
studied greatly a great deal including
Megan's who's right here it works on it
in the mouse hybrids in the European
hybrid zone between mus musculus and
most most Muslims musculus and mrs.
Damascus there's there are there are
sterility issues and incompatibility
issues but there's also genes that are
involved in in transmission distortion
and those that famously have spread
across the hybrid across species
barriers not just the one in in Europe
which is a mild one involving male
sterility but even more severe ones
throughout the range of the genus and so
we have we know that very strongly
favored genes may cross even these
various cross barriers that might seem
to be quite high
so as I was saying that I think if you
just Google genomic scan of
introgression you will see that this is
a cottage industry in the last year or
six months okay and many of the people
who are doing it are doing it because
they have this candy at the sequencing
they haven't actually got a really good
plan for how they're going to analyze
the data and most of the time when you
read about this as well I have a way of
finding some outliers and you know
biologists use but you typical
biologists who is at least partially
motivated by structured function only
needs a few outliers to have the story
to work on then they're done but to do a
sort of full population genomic analysis
of these kind of scenarios is very
challenging and interesting and and for
those of you who don't know I there
there's i'm not completely up on the on
them on the latest and greatest sort of
tweaking of models but i know where to
start thinking about this and and of
course we had a little bit of discussion
of coalescent modeling and and fitting
thinking about analysis in the
coalescence setting in this little paper
classic paper trying to model look at
the distribution of and this is a data
paper that was use this method and
basically they just take they're going
to look for the you have the observed
numbers of segregating sites that are
shared by both species are segregating
sites and only one species one in the
others the numbers that are shared and
the numbers are fixed and that's those
can be represented in actual formal
expression to in terms of these of not
only the sample sizes but these
parameters this is sort of whether it's
on the X or not on the X these are the
population sizes today they ancestral
the time and the
deep flow I guess yeah between them so
you can get a represented at paper a
very simple representation and they
analyze a very small amount of data
actually and already and with a very
small amount of data they already saw
inconsistencies between the low side a
few losa that they observe didn't fit a
single parameter model so already there
was some indication that the less I
didn't really have the same distribution
between and within species then the next
stop on this I think is you you are you
going to be talking about this and the
next day no well anyway he should be
anyway maybe later in the semester but
this these these is a much stronger
extension of the of the effort to
understand these kind of migration
models and how well they fit and there's
a there are of course we have all kinds
of issues with scalability and once we
go to over to the genome and then the
last thing I wanted to point out was
this this paper which I remembered and
and it doesn't doesn't get cited or
refer to that often but it's very
important and and bent was interested is
interested at that time he was
interested in trying to understand the
differential flow genes across a hybrid
zone and he and nick got together and
this is a nice little paper where they
they demonstrate an estimate the sort of
strength or the impact of various
numbers of low side that are under
selection because they produce less fit
hybrids in the hybrid zone and what the
impact of that is on gene flow of linked
neutral SI and they lay out the model
quite nicely but I don't think it's been
as I know have been extended in a sort
of coalescence setting at all that I
know anyway but it's a it's a
formalization one formalization of the
of the selected part of the of the
process and it's at least its
implications for neutral genes that are
linked and one of the conclusions that
they come to in that paper and I don't
know you know it's been a number of
years it could be revisited is that it
really takes a large number of the
density of genes that are under strong
selection in the hybrids has to be
really quite high in order to have a big
impact on the whole genome of course
many people will point out that that's
as I said before many biologists would
be happy with just a few regions of the
genome that showed a really big effect
so that's not necessarily a killer but
from Stan overall standpoint is be
important but i think the other isn't
it's not my idea but it's in bring it to
you because i think it is the time has
come and people are actively trying to
use genome scanning to look at this
hybrid in viability and hybrid isolation
the origin of isolation in the impact of
the isolation genes to use the whole
genome scanning and model and hopefully
modeling to get a better handle on on
the process because if we're going to do
one gene at a time we may never actually
have a the big picture let alone a
genomic representation of speciation
genomics and with that I'll retire
yes we have some yeah we have any
questions yeah um if gene is identified
in one particular species a species a
that is known to be involved in
hydrating authority what are the chances
that it can also be involved in hybrid
natality in another closely or
distributed ated species B&C sit between
drosophila you find a gene which is a
modern hybrid 231 bodybuilders obvious
me what wouldn't other two softness was
heavy and I think I you know no I think
I guess first thing I would say is what
I would I think I said in the beginning
I mean it's 15 years to get six genes
right and so to to take one of these
results and one of the genes is a new
gene right so it's not you're not going
to know then we'll know the the Odysseus
gene Rosen you know it's a duplication
so it's not in the other one but the nut
jeans I think one could it and I don't
know that any nuff genes have been
tested for hybrid sterility specifically
in other species yeah but it's the
manpower horsepower issue and so few of
them that's why you know for example if
you wanted to know whether nup showed
say reduced introgression across hybrid
zones in in if you had five hybrid zones
you could do nuffin another thirteen
thousand genes simultaneously with the
sequencing project and know pretty
quickly at least if it's a big effect
that's shared between number of them so
I think that's exactly the sort of thing
i'm driving out there but it's it's sort
of such an obvious problem to bring
genomics to bear on now that i think of
it
about Odysseus stories so after the
duplication one maintained its
time-honored role and muscle development
and it doesn't seem to budged an inch
just does what it does more or less
unaffected but the duplicated copy bball
very rapidly and with a lot of amino
acid substitutions and became expressed
in the testes and probably some place in
the brain it has new function new
function business neo function was a
that's interpretation from the
expression pattern and the phenotype but
but that one you know i would say about
all of these is it it's hard it's been
hard work to get them and it's actually
my impression is it's been hard work to
understand them because the papers don't
come flowing after they get these things
and when you talk to them you know they
have new function they didn't expect or
the different genetic backgrounds gift
so they're hard to work on it not only
are they are they hard to get so again i
think it's it's not a it's not the kind
of activity i would i recommend people
start their career off doing is chasing
down these genes pretty hard work yeah
Chuck I like this janome skiing movies
they're so damn you know me damn the
problem is you know is your other things
I mean there are lot of things that you
need to differences in
differentiation some of which are
directly in the later the speciation
many approach a lot definitely so you
know Wolfgang showed years ago that
pitch is offline Nancy leads so if we're
looking for the genes that was strict
that they were directly involved in the
front of isolation they're going to be a
subset it may be a very small subset of
those that show high levels of
differentiation genome-wide studies I
just curious to hear your thoughts about
you know how do we dress them well I I
think that is a problem when you're
thinking about a sort of general I mean
for example let's just take drosophila
throughout the world and we're going to
sequence a whole bunch of them and try
to make a demographic bottle I agree
that's the problem but I think a hybrid
zone is a very special kind of situation
because they're you're not talking about
the level overall you're just talking
about the differential diffusion or non
diffusion of us of a variant that you
know exists here is not over there and
so well I think are things that you know
better than I there are lots of things
happening on the hybrid zone that might
not be incompatibility I mean in the
sense of there's ecology and you know
things that are not about mating and but
maybe other things but in any case I
guess my own view would be that's why
God made theoreticians and analysts is
to figure out how to analyze that big
gobs of interesting data and you know
you can do this whole experiment and
convince you know somebody to do the
analysis in the in the four-man years it
takes their woman years or whatever it
takes to get another incompatibility
locus mapped and think so I at least
think we ought to have a parallel Pat
and I think it should be you know like I
said when you google it you get the
distinct impression the sort of a lot of
people are just going ahead without a
plan or a model or anything so i think
it's it's a very good time to sort of
start to make really
concrete models and I think the issue of
the that you raised a sort of the
general population analysis where you
just have subdivision and migration that
one will be more difficult I think to
but they're things are not set up in a
sort of a dynamic tension across it in
hybrid zone do we know the initial
hybrid incompatibilities are driven by
like a small number of low silence or
Japan's knowing what we know is that
geneticists will work on this on a small
number of low side with large effects
that's what we know about genetics
that's what Mendel deity and everybody
sins okay thank you very much